hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today rather than get into a new
in-depth language documentary I decided
to do a fun little video that we can do
together I want to give you a challenge
I want to present you with some mystery
languages and you can listen and look at
those languages and guess what languages
they are but don't worry even if you
don't guess the language correctly it'll
still be interesting as long as you
share the reasons for your guesses in
the comments down below so let's give it
a try
here's the first language please listen
dokie Celtic fellow Tara Munsey excuse
me get my key cousin Oak Island when I
decide to put in sweet Asha famine they
broke and dog with SWAT team tournament
- winnie pooh pooh Mauricio reporter s
Kosuke oh really okay and let me also
show you a little bit of that language
in its written form I don't speak this
language but I'll try to read it as best
I can
game Unni see to keep our eye on Glee
when puck up ballet on Glee so what
language is it
[Music]
the language is Haitian Creole if you're
a French speaker then right away you
might have known that this was Haitian
Creole and other people you might have
noticed some words that sounded French
but sounded a little different that's
because the haitian creole language is a
french-based creole language it arose in
the 17th and 18th centuries because of
interaction between French settlers and
African slaves in the area that is now
called Haiti the majority of its
vocabulary derives from French but the
majority of its syntax to rise from the
African language is spoken by the slaves
let's go back to those two example
sentences for a second game you need to
keep all a Anglais this means is there a
person here who speaks English the
beginning of the sentence doesn't really
seem French Gant means to have or there
is it might derive from the French word
Gagne but the way it's used is quite
different from the French word and moon
means person and I don't know the origin
of this word ect parle Anglais is like
EC key back Longley in French in French
the whole sentence I guess would be Ilya
Kalka and ectp Longley the second
sentence went back up parle Anglais this
means I can't speak English when comes
from moi in French pop is the French
negation marker pas cup comes from the
French kappa blue
parle is partly so the vocabulary is all
kind of French but in French it would be
like this gin sweet-parker pobla de
parler Anglais so obviously the grammar
is very different even though the
vocabulary is French based notice that
in the French sentence my is not used
but sure is used that's because in
French moi is the object pronoun well
Jacques is the subject pronoun in
Haitian Creole when is both now I'm
breaking down these sentences just to
show you that Haitian Creole is a
combination of French and other
influences to learn more about Creole
languages check out my video on pidgins
and creoles right here ok on to the next
language please listen egg William
halibut it can sort fine
he came here through heinous Quora what
a mother Yahoo second beat she helped by
voted up to set out of the ball of olive
all Prolia and yoga nidra blade helper
yoni ma who's the number from the leave
this wonderful set and as far the egg
the for for a shore look and again let
me show you a little bit of that
language in its written form Benna and
upgrading ESL dressing dress as seen
height alone yen greater and more sheets
in Lydon didn't clear for Earvin I trim
the lawn at loft and height and no he
and that for men fan height respond from
them
no evasion so what language is it the
language is frisian specifically west
frisian west frisian is spoken in a
northern province of the netherlands
called Friesland frisson is thought to
be the language that is most closely
related to English now it doesn't mean
that it's easy for English speakers to
understand Frisian when I hear it or
when I try to read it I barely
understand anything but it is closely
related to English in its historical
development and in the structure of the
language alright let's do one last
language please listen and again let's
look at a couple of phrases visually now
I don't speak this language but I'll try
to read these as best I can
non comprendo non Feitosa sorry do me
display giggle so what language is it
well if you know a Romance language then
you probably notice right away that this
is definitely another Romance language
it is actually the Sardinian language
which is spoken on the island of
Sardinia in Italy it is one of many
regional languages in Italy that are
often mistakenly referred to as dialects
but they're actually separate languages
most of them are closely related to
Italian but they are different enough to
be considered different languages well I
hope you enjoyed guessing today's
mystery languages even if you didn't get
them right that's okay it should be
interesting too
share your reasons in the comments down
below and that should spark some
interesting discussion and if you would
like to see more mystery language videos
like this sometime in the future then
let me know and I might do it again be
sure to check out Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and if
you haven't already then be sure to hit
the subscribe button down below
and special thanks to all my patreon
supporters for continuing to make Lange
folk as possible thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]